sur le long chemin de la réconciliation
une nomination symbolique la couronne
britannique au canada sera pour la
première fois représentée par une
autochtone aspects de la vie qu elle
s'appelle mary simon ou nine you good
look dans sa langue maternelle
elle est née dans le grand nord
québécois arnold boldt elle est honorée
et touché face à ses nouvelles
responsabilités et plusieurs femmes
autochtones voit sa nomination comme une
victoire
ma première réaction
un petit wac une fierté l'écrit guittet
c'est incroyable diplomate de carrière
mairie sans émeute a été représentante
inuit lors du rapatriement de la
constitution délégué du canada au
conseil de l'arctique est ambassadrice
au danemark alors que le pays est
confronté à la découverte de tombes
anonymes d'enfants près des pensionnats
pour autochtones
la domination de mary saimone est plus
que symbolique affirme le premier
ministre
je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui va
amener une perspective un poids des
capacités importantes pour le pays en ce
moment de réflexion et de croissance
dans ce contexte comment une autochtone
peut accepter d'être le chef d'état du
pays que certains considèrent comme
l'oppresseur mairie saimone n'y voit pas
de contradiction
alors c'est quand il fait même si voilà
c'est un poste qui est vraiment un
compte spécial dans un système qui est
encore de gouvernance coloniale mais car
quand on doit participer la société puis
il y a la question de la langue
la nouvelle gouverneur général pourra
distribuer les honneurs en hymne aux
petits tout est en anglais mais ne
parlent pas le français
parce qu'il était interdit de parler à
l'école fédérale pour autochtones
qu'elle fréquentait dans les années 50
ça va accrocher la communauté
francophone à travers le canada
ça va accrocher oui certainement moins
c'est ce que j'aurai beaucoup et qu'elle
parle français
la principale intéressée promet de
l'apprendre j'ai pris très au sérieux au
moment où la différence et de la
diversité culturelle et linguistique
l'installation de la 30e gouverneure
générale du canada aura lieu bientôt
la date reste à déterminer c'est à elle
que justin trudeau devra s'adresser s'il
veut déclencher des élections hâtives
mais le premier ministre assure que les
deux n'ont pas encore abordé la question
ici christian noël radio canada ottawa
[Musique]